sont toujours très en forme à la
télévision russe un vraiment je ne sais
pas ce qu'ils prennent mais
votre cas tout commence en tout cas avec
ce reportage pour la télévision russe
avec ce journaliste alexander cote ce
qu'on voit là qui est spécialisé dans
les reportages embarqué avec vera lynn
sigler du z ursula von der leyen
bareback et schultz qui disent que le
génocide des russes dans le combat c'est
ridicule aucun politicien n'avait jamais
rien dit de pire je vais le répéter dans
chaque émission jusqu'à ce que seul ce
le supplie à genoux de le pardonner
quelques heures après la diffusion de ce
reportage de la diffusion des images
aussi sur télégramme gars l'armée
ukrainienne a diffusé à son tour ces
images réalisées par landreau mais sur
lesquelles on peut voir cette arme en
feu sept armes détruites ils pensent
tous que l'on va perdre et que l'ouest
va l'emporter ils ne comprennent pas que
c'est impossible c'est tout simplement
impossible ça n'arrivera jamais soit
nous l'emportons soit ça se terminera
très mal pour toute l'humanité avec la
première ministre et président de la
république avec les maisons s'exprimer
sur les contours sur l'esprit sûr il y
aurait dans ce texte avant très
certainement là le second tour des
élections législatives
beaucoup trop de française beaucoup trop
de français qui vous disent ça me coûte
cher de travailler ça me coûte trop cher
de nourrir ma famille je n'y arrive plus
le travail doit payer les entreprises
qui peuvent augmenter les salaires
doivent augmenter les salaires c'est un
texte peut-être même deux pour tout vous
dire ce matin
possiblement un texte financier qui va
apporter des mesures financières et un
texte d'accompagnement qui portera
d'autres types de mesures c'est un
projet de loi très lourd avec le chèque
alimentaire la politique d' échec par
ailleurs distribué n'importe comment
parce que des députés européens l'ont
reçu quand même faut le dire alors que
moi j'ai croisé des gens qui sont dans
des situations économiques critiques qui
n'ont pas été bénéficiaire de ces
chèques donc le plus simple est de
rendre leur argent aux français et
médias ne sont pas le lieu pour faire le
procès des uns et des autres donc eux il
y à des accusations je rappelle
d'ailleurs qu'il ya une des deux
plaintes qui était classée sans suite
entre 2010 et 2011 premièrement
deuxièmement que ya une présomption de
d'une présomption d'innocence on aurait
pu imaginer qu elisabeth bornes ou
emmanuel macron dix bombes alaïa il ya
une suspicion donc on va laisser six
mois le temps de l'enquète ont saisi le
procureur ont saisi la haute autorité
pour la transparence pour la vie
publique ont saisi le médiateur ont
saisi qui vous voulez on saisit même les
parlementaires pour faire une enquête
parlementaire pendant six mois et au
bout de six mois s'il n'y a rien alors
il reviendra dans le gouvernement c'est
de madame rousseau dont vous parlez oui
que j'ai connu dans ma région et qui est
aujourd'hui candidate candidate à paris
qui voudraient nous nous dire qu'il ya
aujourd'hui un code moral qui doit
remplacer le code pénal c'est le code
pénal qui doit s'appliquer c'est à la
justice
de trancher damien abad s'est exprimé il
est aussi candidat dans le cadre des
législatives il y met en plus du travail
de la justice sa parole personnelle faut
de toute façon que la personne soit
consentante à mon avis pour avoir des
relations sexuelles avec lui parce que
doit falloir l'été quoi femmes soient
pas commun que procéder tout commence au
mois de mars dernier lorsqu'une jeune
femme âgée de 22 ans se présente aux
policiers dans un commissariat parisien
elle explique avoir été la captive
pendant cinq années d'un homme
richissime qui l'a violée récemment cet
homme lui a dit qu'elle était devenue
trop vieille et ses yeux et qu'elles
devaient trouver une remplaçante
en guise de preuve elle remet alors une
vidéo aux enquêteurs sur la vidéo on
aperçoit jacques gautier le patron
d'assu 2000 accompagné d'une jeune
adolescente de 14 ans sur un lit au
total au moins sept jeunes femmes
mineures ou majeures ce serait succédé
dans l'appartement de jacques gauthier à
ses côtés cinq autres personnes ont été
mises en examen sa femme qui aurait été
au courant de ses agissements une jeune
femme chargée du recrutement est
également arrêtés ainsi que trois hommes
de main